[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
happy friday
bonehead of the week
second hour the tony michaels podcast
you guys vote we break it down
we also have a special guest today
missy modell we've had missy on before
we're excited to have missy back today
um i noticed her video that she'd done a
while back as a parody of nine to five
if you guys know missy mandel she does
great musical parodies um all over the
in the interwebs
but she didn't want a while back a
parody of nine to five and it's become
relevant again
because of these republican gq
gqp anti-woman fascists
speaking of anti-woman fascist i'm gonna
show missy a video you guys won't
believe this you won't believe this
i was correct
i always say doubt me
well doubt me again i've i've found
video evidence if you want to call it
that
of an evangelical pastor talking about
how he wants to take the the 19th
amendment away he wants to put women
barefoot and pregnant back in the
kitchen where they [ __ ] belong that's
basically what he says and he uses the
bible as his weapon to do it of course
who else is [ __ ] tired of not
taxing churches in this country i think
it's about [ __ ] time we tax the [ __ ]
out of those [ __ ] what do you
think what do you think if they're so
hell-bent on participating in our
politics
and creating policy for our country i
would say they need to pay some of the
[ __ ] taxes around here i don't know
just a thought
so we're gonna watch i'm gonna i'm gonna
break down this video
uh with missy modell i wanna i wanna
show
um her nine to five video we posted it
over on the the podcast account uh at
tonymichaelspod so go go follow us on
twitter over there at toni michaels pod
i posted the nine to five the clip from
her
her tic toc account actually
um is where i pulled the the clip from
so go follow missy
on tick tock and and instagrams the
instagram is over there
you can just find her at missy modell
that's m-o-d-e-l-l
and you can find her on twitter as well
we got the announcement there on the
podcast twitter page
uh check that out we're gonna missy's
gonna join us hopefully about uh
15 minutes
after the hour so here in about 10
minutes we're going to have missy on
talk about the supreme court decision to
overturn roe v wade and really
the impact that it's going to have on
women missy has been doing parodies
about this for some time now and
speaking about this issue
women have been yelling and screaming
hey
they're gonna try to take our liberty
away
ever since the supreme court in roe v
wade decided to give them the liberty of
their bodily autonomy
and now they want to strip it away you
know they've been working all these
years
you know what's funny about that but
really what really gets me about um
this supreme court leak right
that they're gonna take away americans
liberty right they're gonna take away
their [ __ ] rights their
constitutional right to their liberty of
their bodies
republicans are really [ __ ] pissed
about this leak and i i've said this for
last couple days is that
the reason why republicans are so pissed
off about this leak they can't focus on
anything but the [ __ ] leak
i mean they can't focus on anything i
think they're going to be highly
disappointed when they find who leaked
it
i think they're going to be highly
disappointed to be quite honest with you
they always are it's always you know oh
look here here look at this shiny object
to avoid the discussion of taking away
americans liberty
i mean our next thing is to take away
contraception and then take away women's
votes so they can't vote against us to
take away their liberty
that's what they want to do i'll show
you the [ __ ] video
i'm gonna show you the [ __ ] video
evidence
and just because this one pastor is the
only one brave enough to [ __ ] record
himself saying this [ __ ] that i'm gonna
show you
doesn't mean they all all these [ __ ]
gqp trump humping [ __ ] don't
don't believe this [ __ ] because they do
they certainly [ __ ] do
so we're gonna show you i'm gonna show
you this video
uh later on i i want missy to react to
this video i want to get a woman's
reaction to this video i mean i'm
[ __ ] outraged by this [ __ ]
bonehead saying this [ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] outraged that they
that the consideration would even be
to undo the 19th amendment
they granted
the women's right to vote just over a
hundred years ago
they want to dial the [ __ ] back
over a hundred years folks
you don't think they won't dial it back
200 years
i'm talking about even [ __ ] slavery
doubt me
[ __ ] doubt me i'm no i know within
the next few months with this debate
over liberty contraception women's
rights the [ __ ] that's going on in
ukraine
this constant [ __ ]
dumbing down of america with trumpism
and the fascism in a [ __ ] manga hat
that it is
the south will rise again we are in a we
are in a situation where they can't
think about anything but the state's
rights to be a cheeto dust confederacy
it's where we're at
that's
[ __ ] where we're at
and it's up to us
the pro-democracy folks the people who
still believe
that the voice of the people is the way
forward regardless of how divided we may
be on one issue to the next
there are a hell of a lot more
pro-democracy people out there
than these these [ __ ] trump-humping
fascists
and we see that just
just in recent days when people are
pointing out the support that isn't
there for reversing roe v wade
in the reddest of the red states they
can't even hump up 30 percent support to
get rid of roe v wade and because the
secret is folks
that the trump hump and fascist they use
abortion services too
this is a really [ __ ] stupid idea
that religious people don't use abortion
services because the medical decisions
that a person or a woman specifically in
this case makes about their body a lot
of times has [ __ ] not a god damn
thing to do with religion not a [ __ ]
thing
not a [ __ ] thing
and nor should it and nor should we make
it
a religious thing to have a to make a
medical decision you people are [ __ ]
lunatics you're out of your god damn
minds
and there i believe if we mobilize and
we get the correct messaging here folks
i think we're gonna have a coalition
like you've never seen before
people who consider themselves
conservatives going to the polls and
absolutely destroying trumpism because
they're going to see trumpism for what
it is they're [ __ ] banning math
in florida
ron desantis is banning math in florida
and he's act like he's [ __ ] cutting
taxes because he's gonna have some kind
of one-month moratorium 12 years from
now on gasoline tax in florida and he's
acting like he's cutting taxes when he's
raising taxes by [ __ ] stripping away
disney special district status and
taxing floridians on their property
because he just can't stand mickey mouse
mickey mouse gay or i don't know some
[ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ] this is
about they've lost their [ __ ] minds
they're they're all in the tail is
wagging the dog and they're all in on
fascism and american fascism at that
you know what you know it's it's fascism
in a manga hat it's trumpism
the um the american taliban as it were
the q anon religion
that's where we're at folks
that's where the [ __ ] we're at
it's a cult it's a [ __ ] cult this is
great you'll love this
i happen to be watching
um last night or the night before oh
brother where art thou
on the streaming service
i was doing some things and i had it
playing in the background
and my daughter come in the room and
she's seeing on the screen the part
where there's the the kkk rally
and the first thing she said when she
seen what was happening on the screen
she said
is that a cult
[Laughter]
she said it she said is that a cult
and i said yep
it's a cult
it's a cult
that was it that was the
brain simple discussion
holy [ __ ]
we also found out this week
with this
mark esper holding all this information
that would have been nice for the
american voters to i i you know i think
if all this information that they sold
for profit in these books you know
haberman [ __ ] bill barr john bolton
esper now uh stephanie what the [ __ ]
her face
you know she she i say what
grisham is her name but what's the
[ __ ] her face because she was the
press secretary no one even knew it
because she didn't even see who's the
[ __ ] she was
they sold all these books sold all this
information that the american people
wanted
should have known about this
[ __ ] mussolini jesus that they s that
they praise that there is their cult
leader
here we have mark esper trying to profit
off information that voters could have
used to make decisions about our
democracy
we find out
that donald trump
oh my god and this is why i made it the
uh
the title of the show trump bombing of
mexico
you remember when we found out that he
was gonna he wanted the nuke the the
hurricane you remember this he wanted to
make the
hurricane
nuclear oh [ __ ]
you know his bright idea yeah he saw it
he saw it on a facebook iver mekhton
group and he thought ah well you know he
should try it out well he wanted to bomb
mexico
and this morning his dumb [ __ ] son
has coked out son donald trump jr
is like yeah well why wouldn't you want
to bomb mexico like he literally was
like yeah sure yeah we're on that side
so literally in the next couple weeks
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] [ __ ] at
these rallies is gonna be i'm telling
you we're gonna have tape of it don't
doubt me do not doubt me i'm telling you
right now mark my [ __ ] words we're at
13 and a half minutes into the podcast
13 and a half minutes in you just mark
my words
at the rally this weekend or next
weekend whenever the [ __ ] they have the
next nazi queuing on rally whenever that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is
i'd rather eat a big bag of dog [ __ ]
than go to a trump rally but whenever
that [ __ ] rally is the next one
there are going to be people standing on
stage saying into a microphone
that you goddamn right we want to bomb
mexico why wouldn't you of course you
would that's the smartest thing on the
planet is to bomb mexico they're gonna
say that [ __ ] folks 100 percent full
stop they're going to be all in for
bombing mexico i ain't [ __ ] yet
i'm not kidding you they're they're
going to say that [ __ ] out loud into a
microphone and act like that's what the
majority of americans want is some sort
of [ __ ] hot war with mexico because
we want to bomb cartels
when the real news is is that the biden
administration has stopped
a gazillion times more
drugs coming across the [ __ ] border
than the trump administration would ever
[ __ ] dream of they're doing their
[ __ ] job
stopping the [ __ ] fentanyl from
coming in our country
they're doing their job
but trump
let's bomb them you know forget about
actually doing your job and protecting
the border and protecting americans from
illicit fit and all coming from across
the border and actually you know
considering actual drug policy in this
country that would prevent a lot of the
illegal drugs you know marketable coming
across the [ __ ] border forget about
all that forget about that you know what
we should do we should stop vegetable
trucks at the border and check their
tire pressure so all those vegetables go
bad and cost americans gazillions of
dollars we shouldn't worry about the
[ __ ] drugs we should just bomb
mexicans you people
have lost your [ __ ] minds debbie says
crystal ball yeah i'm telling you
i'm telling you
just just wait just wait it's gonna
happen
i want to welcome everyone to the show
thank you for thank you for watching
now we got a lot of people over on
facebook watching you guys know we
simulcast to midas touch facebook page
nowadays
so welcome to all the books of facers
are facers of book
i don't know
all you out there are meta universers
i don't know i have no idea i have no
idea what it what you're supposed to be
called
all the people on facebook thanks for
joining us you know every single weekday
we broadcast live
monday through friday
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch
you can go to youtube and just search
the tony michaels podcast and subscribe
there don't forget to subscribe
to the youtube channel you can also find
us on facebook simulcasting to the midas
touch facebook page so give us a like
over there
and then once we're done with the show
when it's live here's what happens for
all the new listeners out there
we actually go upload it download it
sideways load it whatever you do to
apple spotify and google
that way you can download the the audio
version
every single weekday two hours
good news is
we do a special
and bonus episodes during the weekend uh
saturdays we're doing a best of the week
so we take the the clips from the best
of the week we put it in one episode and
you can download it
on apple spotify google you can watch it
on youtube twitter twitch and also on
the minus touch facebook page and also
especially special for sunday is the
bonus episode of bonehead of the week
you guys know it's friday and friday
what we do is we go through the bonehead
of the week poll
and during the bone hand of the week
poll we go through
the poll that you vote for bonehead of
the week
and here's here's the best part about
bonehead of the week we break it down
every single friday in the second hour
of the show
and then
on sundays we repost just the bonehead
of the week on youtube twitter twitch
and now
to the minus touch facebook page we
simulcast it
and you can actually download it on
google apple and spotify so don't forget
to go subscribe to all those channels
all those channels uh we're still
working out um
getting my co-host gabe sanchez and
missy modell on looks like
uh we're still working there gabe you
got your you got your audio ready there
is he giving me the thumbs up
okay yeah
that microphone is a son of a [ __ ] over
there isn't it it is it is uh it is
something well sometimes when i like
plug in i've got this external audio
thing and i plug it in
register
see
this guy this guy this guy well welcome
to friday gabe it is friday we're here
how did how did the uh how did the bone
end of the week pull go over on youtube
you know the fans requested to have it
on youtube
okay everything worked the numbers
everything added up to 100
i had to post it for some reason i i
must have to give you permission to i
think i have to be a complete admin or
owner of the channel i can't just be the
the step below they don't give you i got
you get everything off but the community
said uh
really so so you can post anything you
want yeah i can do anything i want with
the channel outside of delete it but you
know well right why would we want to do
that you're really you're gonna you're
gonna upset all the listeners here by
telling them i'm just saying everybody
go subscribe wait wait everyone go
subscribe to the youtube channel before
gabe deletes it
um you've got
time as a ticket tick tick tick tick
tick tick well or for youtube delete it
i was really concerned um everybody
knows we we reviewed the uh madison
cothorn uh hump dump uh video yeah
that's a huge hump day
pump day yeah hump day play or hump day
dump or what whatever the hell i eat
anyways yeah let's let's not get back on
that topic too much but i was surprised
i was surprised that youtube left that
video up they left it up yeah well we
got i think well this morning we got
like 1200 views on youtube so
people like to see that i think it's the
face
but i i think the funniest part is when
it's just like
right
right this it's hilarious it's i don't i
i was really unsure
how the censored quote-unquote video
would turn out but the way that the head
the face on his ass
really you know to cover the butt mohawk
or whatever it was yeah yeah because
really i mean the ass cheeks weren't
that offensive it was the
whatever that is
yeah anyways don't need to go we don't
need to go into that anymore if people
would want to know what we had to say
about it feel free to go check out
yesterday yesterday's episode download
it was it yesterday or was it the day
before i lose track what we're talking
about it was yes
are our an anal sis as i call it
uh
yeah anal you know analysis oh oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but it was the day before we
had on uh katie mandel yeah jd mandel
who made fun of jd vance who was an
analyst for cnn right you know actually
i so what i did is i put together a
playlist for for you guys to go watch
just our parody and satire and i think
gabe we're gonna try to put more um like
some of your commercials that we play
maybe we'll put those maybe we'll put
we'll make some more content that maybe
we'll do some exclusive content just
there and we'll like tease it on the
exclusive and then and then we'll play
it maybe teasing on the show or
something and then look if there is if
there is something that happens out
there is there if there's a person that
makes themselves an idiot
or you know people want to see this
character on the show
let us know
write it in the comments you know
uh and we'll make sure that they make a
cameo yeah because we got we got a
couple eric trump um videos there
um there's the the letters from the
tracker convoy that's a an all-time
favorite for everybody let's see what
else oh some of our rnn videos like
white privilege tonight with uh uh
what carl tuckerson i believe is right
right right and then
is on there i also want to let people
know that when when characters come on
the show we have no idea where this is
gonna go right it is completely
improvised we have an idea of like oh
who the character is right but what is
really talked about in the stuff
that whole thing
yeah one of the best one of the best and
it's the video is over on youtube on
this playlist it's a satire satire or
parody and satire that's what i call it
i i maybe i need to move it up in the
list too so it's like at the very top
yeah i think you just bump it up that'll
help yeah yeah but you know that the
best part about
the the the one that we did the most i
think it was like 40 minutes when eric
trump came on oh yeah there was a lot of
he cried a lot he talked about how he's
getting coffee right literally uh you i
think you dm me and said hey eric trump
is coming on today and that was like the
yeah that was the max amount of pride i
mean just like when i came in as heidi
cruz i didn't know what i was doing i
had no idea wig on because i was
cleaning i should cut that one too i
don't think we cut that one we should
find we should yeah yeah we should find
that and cut that out we should find all
those and cut those and put those in the
in the uh the parody satire you guys
know we like to make you laugh because
sometimes like yesterday when we had to
go through the the madison cothorn
whatever the hell that humping video was
sometimes it just you can't get away
from the disgusting gqp so you gotta
laugh about it now it is hard to parody
them
in reality it's it's very hard because
they parody themselves so the satire is
very difficult but we try our best
and i i feel like um some of the videos
that we've made and some of the stuff
that the content that we've produced um
for the parody and satire is is really
good you guys should go watch it that's
why we made the playlist so go
uh go again go subscribe to the channel
and check out that playlist i i actually
posted it on my twitter account
this morning the link to that playlist
so and subscribe to that playlist
because again maybe we just gave maybe
we just try to keep maybe do some
special stuff that's not even in the
show that to give these people some
something a way to laugh about it you
guys want it you know it's because we
got to clown these we'll give it to you
that's always our uh that's always our
way speaking speaking
you got a thumbs up there missy speaking
of uh okay cause she's good speaking of
parody and satire uh i want to welcome
to the show we've had we've had uh the
great missy modell on before which uh we
love we love missy here missy how are
you
oh i'm doing great hey
hey how are you this is fantastic i love
having you on i love being here i was
just telling the crew that i needed to
be here again so here we are
great well you know i actually um i when
i when i first heard
about the
um the leak of
reversing roe v wade i had a lot of
people in mind you were one of the ones
and the reason why is because you've
done a lot of video parody video on
women's rights for contraception and
even the right to your bodily autonomy
so you like came to the forefront
and um you know so i've one i wanted to
have you on since we've heard that some
other ones uh a morgan fairchild she's
been in this fight for a long time so
there's some others that we really want
to try to get on the show um
to talk about this because i think a
woman's voice is
more important than any at this time and
but but i want to play something here
let me see if i can find it here on on
twitter i posted it this morning you
both for using your platform to talk
about this because i want to see more
men talking about this as well it's
great for women to talk about it but we
need everybody to be speaking about it
because this is a human rights issue
that doesn't just affect women and
people that get pregnant
i i think you're i think you're
absolutely right that if men aren't
pissed that their their mothers their
wives their daughters their sisters uh
their friends their colleagues
are having their liberty stripped away
from them and don't think that they're
not next like if you're like
it's not just about
making sure that one group of people has
rights and liberty because if we start
to erode rights and liberty away from
this group here and that group here and
this group here we really do live in a
fascist state um and i'm going to show
you a video that i want you to react to
because i've been saying
since the the announcement of roe v wade
or the the announcement of the leak it
were you know they're real concentrated
on a leak as if you know taking away
people's liberty yeah that's second that
second fiddle to having someone leak the
fact that we're taking away rain is
ridiculous but i've been saying that
they're gonna want to
to repeal the 19th amendment which we
know just over a hundred years ago
the 19th amendment granted women the
right to vote and they're going to do
everything in their power to try to
circumvent to bang up that because there
is going to be a coalition of feet in
the streets and it's not just going to
be women it's going to be men too
and but i want you to respond but first
video i want to play is this video you
did a while ago um it's a parody of nine
to five it's classic missy here
um so let me let me play this video
what's that am i reacting to myself no
no i just want to i just want to say
live react from my star i want
i want the audience to see this video
because when did you do this video by
the way
i did this for the yellow fun foundation
so i believe it was three years ago
and
it was when doctors the big thing was
that doctors would get 99 years for
helping or supporting somebody who's
pregnant get an abortion so i called it
99 because the doctors would get 99
years so it's a bit of a specific
tone but still very much relevant to
what we're dealing with today
well and really you know everyone keeps
saying i have a crystal ball because
i've been saying this week that they're
going to come after a women's vote and
then i posted a video of a of a pastor a
very uh famous provocateur pastor who
said hey i want women barefoot in in the
kitchen and they shouldn't have the
right to vote
so i'm gonna play that that's the one i
want you to react to but let's listen to
uh missy's version parody version here
of nine to five
tumbled out of it and i stumbled to the
kitchen for myself a cup of restriction
and screaming crying try to come to life
gotta cross state lines and my blood is
pumping i'll find a back alley where
i'll be jumping i'll find some folks
cause i'm scared i'm gonna die
[Music]
all right so uh go follow missy there
you go there's the tick tock handle at
missy model on tick tock i pulled that
off your tick tock uh this morning yeah
thank you we made you uh made you the
the graphic there so we could so we
could play it and then i post on twitter
i was like ah she gets a point on the
show about nope i'm gonna let the
twitterverse because i've seen it on
instagram several different places
people are sharing that video around um
because it is a very catchy parody song
but you almost tell the the future in it
missy because it's not hard to know what
these
these gq peers these these fascists
these anti-women
who claim to be pro-life who are
absolutely
even
uh tossing aside the exception of the
woman's life which seems exact opposite
of that and i mean the thing that's so
absolutely mind-boggling to me is that
even if there are certain situations in
which an abortion is literally the
treatment so if you have an ectopic
pregnancy
what the only way to survive is to abort
the
pack of cells or the sac whatever clump
of cells that is not yet a person but
they want to re-implant those cells in
the woman
it makes or in the person it makes
it's i don't know it's almost like a
surreal experience i have to be honest
that i'm actually living through it
because i feel like it's one thing to
see it hypothetically but to actually
see things at a draft that is in the
final stages of getting past the
legislature it is
well i mean it's yeah it's it
you've got a group of guys who are
gaslighting women to say that'll never
happen
you're so crazy stop being so emotional
like the standard kind of [ __ ] of
like how do we sweep this to the side
and focus on the real things that matter
um
[Music]
and like banning math and yeah like
banning math it's like well how you know
whatever it's like how okay anyway but
yeah it's it it is insane and it is
unfortunate that we live in these times
but it again is
is something where
you know realists right we live in
reality we understand what's going to
happen
and these people are like oh no we're
never going to do that and then
immediately turn their back and go [ __ ]
all these people right like that's
well you know i have a graphic here i'll
sells the evangelicals who really really
having their way with the eyeball in the
plump cells and actual children are
pissed off
because evangelical christians do not
give two shits about yeah once you're
out they don't give a [ __ ] about you
right well george carlin i posted a
video it went freaking viral on my
twitter again it was like six million
views it's not me it's george garland
but he said he said uh
what he says the quote is if you're
pre-born you're fine if you're preschool
you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] i mean
because that's the truth they really
don't give a [ __ ] about women they don't
give a [ __ ] about the children that they
may or may not bear or they may force
them
to bring to term or like you said even
carry them even if it's not even a
viable pregnancy to the point to where
the woman would actually
die
i mean it's it's it really is ridiculous
also the thing that really was
astounding to me yesterday was when matt
gates was calling women that are over
educated so what does that even mean
well they know they know more they know
more than they need to know to be
oppressed gabe yeah
they they secretly kept all those
textbooks that were banned and that
makes them overeducated yeah right matt
gates the man who is currently under
investigation for sex trafficking
and sex with a minor and paying for such
sex acts on venmo like that guy has the
he doesn't want those girls who he's
purchasing on venmo to to be educated
about you know sex education and
underage sex i mean as i said underage
and undervalued on venmo is what matt
gates and that's how that's what he
wants that's how he likes his women i
can't even believe we have a joke about
this but this is where we're at it it it
is the [ __ ] up reality we live in but
yes uh
i just want to say matt gates can go
[ __ ] himself yeah well all the way off
all the way yeah i just wondered like do
you actually believe it or at a certain
point is it just like talking heads and
they or they just want to say things
that they know is going to get a
reaction
i think it will i think whether the
whether they believe it or not i think
well i think there's a small truth to
what they say but also there might be
something where it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy like if you say
it enough times
then do you kind of ingrain that and you
go i believe i am this man i believe
this [ __ ] like that's
i think you you very well could be like
oh i 100 when i say this i mean it and
then there could be people are like
because tony and i talked about
yesterday but like locker rooms and that
type of like you're you're a teenager
and you want to fit in so i'm gonna
i'm gonna contribute to the hazing of
someone else right um and i think that
psychology also plays a role like if
you're in an influential leadership
position you're in congress you're in
the senate or you're a politician you
also want to as a freshman or early on
you also want to fit in so you probably
want to say the same things that
everyone else in the party's saying
because you don't want to feel like
you're going to get extradited or you're
going to get uh become the black sheep
and they get primaried right
so i i think there is an element of that
too where it's like you may not
ultimately like wholeheartedly believe
that when you first come in
but if you're around those people enough
that toxic culture oh that for sure will
stain the soul that you have you know
it's almost like that um experiment the
prisoner and the guard oh the stanford
experiment
it's like that it's like
power or hypothetical power or
metaphorical power it's like you
eventually start yielding that too and
abuse it yeah and exactly yeah
yeah well you know
speaking of a locker room dog and all
this i have a video i want you to review
but um
did you and i'm not gonna show this
video uh again but did you see the
madison cawthorne trying to do his power
over whatever
it is it is a very disturbing video and
a lot of people thought it was like a
sexual thing but me and gabe i i that
was not my view of it my view is it was
not a sexual thing i think this is when
we talked about this yesterday like this
is what they're afraid of like it they
they have this uh uh really gross these
[ __ ] scumbags have a really gross
rapey type um power over people and it's
not just women it's men as well and they
exhibit it in this uh display that
kawthorne had in this video you know i i
believe it would that's what it was um
the point that i'm trying to make here
outside the video is that
they um
they use their butt mohawks to hump and
dump america maybe i guess is if you
want to put it that way but really is
that it is about misogyny at most
and
at at best they are terrified that that
misogyny comes off as a homosexual
tendency and that's what they're they're
terrified because i don't think madison
cawthorn is is gay i don't believe i
don't i mean i i unless he would say he
was i don't you know i take it at face
value that he says he's not whatever and
i don't think that those videos show
that he is gay i think it shows that
he's terrified of homosexual tendencies
that's why he he
he absolutely
absolutely is a bigot towards anyone in
the lgbtq community because he's
terrified of those homosexual tendencies
that he obviously has practiced with his
misogyny over other people and his this
macho machismo thing so and i'm going to
show you a video here about macho
machismo misogyny it's and and all
hiding behind religious dogma in the
bible which is really [ __ ] gross but
um
i i don't know this
this whole culture and that's what it is
that's what the video of madison
cawthorne is that's what the whole mat
gets pretending like he and when he
tweets this vile [ __ ]
um about women being overeducated as if
someone could be over educate like what
the what are you talking about how do we
pronounce his last name is it guess or
gates
i i say
i intentionally
but i intentionally mispronounce it
missy sorry i say gets because i i hate
that [ __ ] and i'm gonna i hope
if he ever watches any video where i say
his name it pisses him off that i say
his name wrong that's why i say it wrong
or not it's like i don't even care to
pronounce her last name
[ __ ] him okay so let's watch this video
of another example
of macho machismo
you know
yes it it's
listen
to all you guys out there that are
listening you can be manly without
having to be an [ __ ] and a [ __ ] an
anti-woman like actually to be pro-woman
is to be [ __ ] manly and
honestly if you think you're going to
get laid by being against the
very people that you may want to get
laid by it's probably like literally i
don't understand this stuff like i don't
get it if you want to be manly if you
want to be a true man
stand up for women stand up for your
sisters your mother your daughters like
that's the [ __ ] manly thing to do you
came from a woman right why are you
hating where are you where you you hung
out for nine months right right great
place they fed you they housed you they
took care of you right and then you
reason why you're here right and then
you're just going to turn around and
[ __ ] on everyone else who has to then
bear a child and you're like yeah well
man i don't really care it's like come
on man
potty mouth polly pollyanne i believe is
her name she's on
twitter and tick tock and the instagrams
i believe um she posted this video and
if you can't read it here it says
example
number eight seven six two so
8762 why i left the church and no longer
believe there are a few millions after
that number yeah i'm sure yeah right
this is a toxic bs and also it says
evangelical pastor preaches uh women
should not be allowed to vote or get
jobs outside the house this is
i've been saying for days that they are
going to come after the 19th amendment
and they may oh you're oh you're being
hysterical told me i'm like i'm telling
you that's the next step is
contraception and the women's right to
vote is right behind that baby oh boy
they're going to be talking about it
let's listen here those horrible
horrible days when women had no right
right let's bring them back
let's get back to those days
what are you so worried about what do
you think they mean when they say
women's rights
okay i want to stop there because here's
the thing he is literally saying that we
should go back to the day when women
have no rights and people shouldn't be
hysterical about it because it's a it's
a good thing now the other thing i want
to point out is this is not like some
audience member catching this bonehead
saying [ __ ] off the cuff and then
posting it on the internet this guy is
professionally producing this video and
publishing it for everyone to see
i guess he's like banned in like 30
countries or some [ __ ] i'll try to yeah
i'll try to i'll try to bring up what
state is this guy in
um i'm not real sure it's pastor stephen
anderson if you want to he's a great guy
yeah oh yeah he's great great at a party
for sure yeah i didn't i didn't even
have to type in the full name i put
pastor yes
and stephen anderson oh my god came
right up so this guy is a really popular
for his antics i mean really honestly he
could be maybe the most punchable face
in america right now i don't know i
don't know
don junior's another but you know
whatever it happens let's listen to what
pastor stephen will puke up here like
you know what they mean they're right go
ahead and we'll go ahead missy oh i said
i'm like breaking out in hives
i know it's gross it's gross but here's
the thing and i tell my audience this
all the time you have to see this stuff
because if we completely ignore like and
and cast off all this pastor stephen
anderson what the hell no one's gonna
listen to him he's a crazy person like
mike lindell the my pillow nazi was in
the [ __ ] white house when they were
trying to commit a coup like what are
you talking about what are you drawing
they are listening to the crazy that is
where they're getting all these [ __ ]
great ideas they have
it really i can't understand it but
let's listen to
what we have to understand here i mean
the right to divorce your husband is
what they mean
you know what they mean the right to
rebel and disobey your husband the right
to divorce him the right to go out and
get a job and make your own money the
right to tell him what to do the right
to go vote for our leaders as if women
should have any say in how our country
is run
so listen this guy is saying
that he would love to hold for men to
hold women prisoner that is what he's
saying he's basically saying men have
the right to own women is what he is
saying in this video i can't interpret
in any other way do you are you
interpreting in a different way married
yeah he's married
i feel sorry i'll tell you once we
finish this i'll tell you the info
behind them i need to see yeah yeah well
and i think i'll be able to pull up some
um some like uh graphics some some
people posted below
about this about this guy in the in the
thread but let's finish listening
to this absolute ridiculousness when the
bible says that i suffer not a woman to
teach nor to usurp authority over the
man but to be in silence
i am quoting the bible right now but
it's old-fashioned why do you think that
women were not allowed to vote until the
20th century and yet if i get up and say
i don't believe women should vote
because if we're in a democracy which is
ruled by the people i don't want to be
ruled over by women
woo
well i mean you know this guy's got an
opinion right holy [ __ ]
you know how how nice it is sometimes
when as a guy i'm like i don't have to
make a decision right right like if it's
like oh what if you know what are we
going to go what are we going to do my
girlfriend's like are we going to go do
this
great great like didn't have to didn't
have to make a decision didn't have the
opportunity to [ __ ] this up like let's
just
i
wholly like i really would like
a female leader just to make the
decisions
and control the governing body
because we you know tony and i said
before like
men have [ __ ] it up for all of you
way too long 12 children
yeah he has 12 children yeah just like
the disciples one of them is going to
backstab him just saying i mean based on
the bible if i'm using his words uh
one of them will be judas and one of
them will stab him in the back for 30
pieces of silver we can only hope that
guy is very unhinged honestly oh yeah
well some people were saying like in the
thread is it true that he's banned from
30 countries is that
i don't know if he's banned from 30
countries but basically what i'm reading
is so he's a
faithful word baptist church in tempe
arizona
um he
had
advocates for the death penalty for
homosexuals and prayed for the deaths of
former us president barack obama and
caitlyn jenner
he produces different movies and films
he's been banned from many countries
including jamaica canada
uh ireland australia and new zealand
there probably are more beyond that
um but he is listed
um
by the
what did i just see
uh southern poverty yeah yeah
yep as anti-gay uh the guy is a [ __ ]
hot
mess yeah like a dumpster fire of [ __ ]
with gasoline on it how gay do you think
he is oh well i mean
it it is apparent that he is terrified
of his
own own deficiencies as he sees it right
his own and this that's the craziest
part about this whole thing
is this guy sees that if he has a woman
tell him to do something he's not enough
of a man that's his deficiency like what
are you talking that's not a deficiency
that's that's a [ __ ] feature man
that's the whole point like let someone
smarter and better at this stuff tell
you what you should think and do like
you shouldn't be telling a woman what
the [ __ ] happens inside her body like
what how do you know what it what the
hell is it any of your business to know
anyways so let them tell you let them
describe the experience like that's the
whole point and and again with this he
views lgbtq obviously if he's praying
for the death of caitlyn jenner jesus
christ that he views this as a
deficiency
and he's projecting his own deficiencies
in this stuff what he sees as
deficiencies these are not deficiency
deficiencies this not what these things
are but it's this [ __ ] culture that
we talked about with this madison
cawthorne all these leaks that are
coming out not just the videos but you
know the sex orgies and all this stuff
they they see those things as
deficiencies even though they want to
participate in these deficiencies they
have to project the opposite so no one's
on to them so you're probably right
missy is that i mean again it's very
much that if i can't be happy with my
true self
because the party i'm in or the group i
you know i'm sorry i gotta cohabitate
with or whatever yeah thank you uh
i can't look at that [ __ ] anymore uh
if yeah if you're in a situation like
this like
these people
cannot feel comfortable in their own
bodies because the people they're around
and in the scriptures they learn from
even though it doesn't say that uh or or
or the groups that they uh
interact with they are saying that this
is
unethical this is illegal this is
immoral all these things and so then you
say why i can't be my true self i can't
come out and say hey i am one way or the
other because i'm afraid of how the
party's gonna react right
and
this is a situation where
i would say a majority of republicans
you know if they could be them true
selves then they wouldn't be so hateful
and
divisive they could be whatever they
need
you mean they can get votes they can get
votes look here people would actually
want to yeah fred fred wilhelm posted
this this is a real thing
i'm not sure how many uh different ways
that happened
and vote in every election republican
candidate accused of killing his wife
wins township board primary race in
indiana from
jail
with 60
of the 276 total votes this is the guy
apparently he is in
jail right now because he is accused is
he in jeopardy
like is he getting out of jail
i don't i don't know the actual well no
i think i think the um he got charged
with murder so he's just charged is what
it is um his name
let me see let's see if i can find his
name um i'll click the link here and
then gabe if you want to find something
on this guy uh
the man charged with murder his name is
andrew
wait let me let me pull this out will
hoyt yeah willow was charged in march
for with killing his wife elizabeth
nicki will hoit 41. she had completed
her last chemotherapy treatment oh my
god
for breast cancer and was seeking a
divorce after she found her husband had
been having an affair so you know not
only is this guy
cheating on his wife who has cancer
oh my god okay uh when he's he's being
held in boone county apparently without
bond because he's he's being charged
with her murder so
once but he won
he won his election though
allegedly struck her in the head with a
concrete gallon-sized flower pot placed
her in the car and dumped her body
nearby creek
yeah we don't want to get in trouble
here allegedly right yeah allegedly this
guy
he allegedly won an election too because
republicans are allegedly scumbags no
not allegedly they are scumbags right
they are so it says his jury trial is
scheduled to begin in late august and
his name will be removed as if it
shouldn't have not been already already
removed but it says his name will be
removed from the ballot if he is
convicted of a felony before the general
election on november 8th awesome he also
has the option of removing his name from
the bell before july 15th but has not
done so as of early friday
according to records
i have a question that's not related but
i was just wanted to take again if
you've seen anything
for the my body my choice argument and i
know there's you know with masks how so
loud so vehemently my body my choice has
anybody
retaliated on the other side
about my body my choice has anyone's
been like well actually it's different
because like what is their argument when
they're comparing well they're men
they're men yeah so here's the thing it
is their body their choices you know
your your body is their choice too
totally but they're i mean it's it's my
body my choice i put a mask on it right
it's to avoid a contagious
virus and for them pregnancy also is a
contagious like is like that's that's
the logic i see it's like one is not the
same to the other but in their mind they
say my body my choice don't tell me what
i can put on my face but i can put in my
body all these things to protect myself
against a deadly virus and then the
other is they're saying well my body my
choice but i get to choose what you do
with your body
uh because pregnancy is contagious like
it doesn't it doesn't make the same but
there is no logic behind it they equate
one to the other and then they're like
well death is death and it's like it's
not the same
they would be like well your body your
choice like you're fighting for it so
what about my body my choice so now that
it's actually going into effect where
this is right it's like listen if you
want to be an idiot you don't want to
wear a mask and you want to get a
vaccine fine that is your body that is
your choice and whatever the outcome is
whatever the bills and debt you get into
if it's death at the end that's on you
and you just won a darwin award but
if you then want to play that same game
against women you you can't right
because you're the one who's like don't
come near me government overbearing
government and then they're the same
group that's like hey overbearing
government control what these women do
with their bodies
well here's the thing is that these
these things and and i think these men
miss this
this my body my choice and and they miss
it all the time these elon musk trump
humping fools these freedom of speechers
who think that they can run around the
country with their white dumb asses
their privileged white dumbasses and
there's no consequences for anything
right like like i can do what you know
the joe rogan tags i can do whatever i
want whenever i want with no consequence
and [ __ ] you right because i'm white and
i can do it and i'm a man too by the way
right but here's the thing is there what
they don't understand is there's
consequences for anything that you do
anything and to
to not understand that for a woman to
have an abortion rather it is for a
medical procedure to save her life
rather it is to to
to get rid of a clump of cells that was
that was forcefully implanted by a
rapist or incest or it it is just a
procedure that they absolutely do not
want that pregnancy they don't
understand that those steps that a woman
would take
have consequences they think that oh a
woman get rid of a baby she's freeing
herself like what are you talking about
she has to live with that decision for
the rest of her life
regardless of why she made it or how she
made it just like she has to live with
the decision if she carries the baby to
term and wants that baby i don't
understand how they don't get that every
one of your choices your freedoms and
your rights have consequences just like
your [ __ ] speech
i say all kinds of crazy [ __ ] on this
show and i certainly pay the
consequences rather i get listeners who
agree with me and who watch this show
thank you very much to all the listeners
out there or if i get people who [ __ ]
hate me and who who want to cancel me or
whatever that's the consequence that is
the consequence of me talking into this
microphone because i make the decision
to do it missy
i'm i'm sure that every consequence when
you make a parody video is all good
right or is it all bad i mean you you
have
there's consequences when you make
decisions right about this before yeah
no like you put yourself out there you
have the ability to use your voice
for however you want to use it and
there's going to be a consequence right
exactly
well speaking of consequences because uh
the mask i'm trying to look for this
video me and gabe played the howard
stern video and he makes such a great
point about the mask wearing thing if i
can find it
there are two things i want to remind
everyone who's listening or watching
when it comes to an abortion right if a
woman chooses that she is not in the
right
situation to to raise a child that's a
totally valid reason all right so you
can just stop right there and the other
thing is it is 100 none of your [ __ ]
business
like that that at the end of the day
it's like if though
the the latter of the two is what
everyone should remember
it's none
of your [ __ ] business a woman does
what her body with what she wants to do
you do with what your body with what you
want to do
no one's trying to control you no one's
trying to make you get a vasectomy and
if they were i guarantee the [ __ ]
line of protesting men
would be around the corner they'd be
storming the supreme court they would be
smearing [ __ ] all over the documents i
guarantee it
you know what i can't wait for i can't
wait for the day to science to be able
to implant an unwanted pregnancy into a
man's body
and what was the movie what was the
movie with arnold schwarzenegger where
he had a baby i mean that was willingly
for an experiment but like what was what
is that oh it had danny jamie jr no no
that was twins that was twins was it
junior i don't know but it has danny
devito in it danny devito is in the in
that one too twins and this one oh yeah
he is that's right anyway yeah junior is
the one where he as a man has a baby
right uh i haven't seen it i don't know
if it ages well but the idea that a man
can have a baby sure it ages pretty
quickly it's a 90s movie uh yeah yeah
anyway but yeah junior i haven't seen it
in years again i don't know if it ages
well but that's the only one where i've
ever been like oh hey the reality of a
man having a baby and
and dealing with that like
no imagine a world though where science
could implant
an unwanted a clump of cells into a
man's body that a man if a man signs up
to to make sure that no clump of cells
is ever eradicated then sure if you're
volunteering for our our national
registry of right
i don't know maybe maybe they would be
they're not going to be for that they
wouldn't be okay well what if what if we
look okay here's here's a hypothetical
what if we lived in a in a world in the
future where
it was no longer just the woman right so
kind of go on your idea like it was 23
chromosomes of a baby in the man and the
23 chromosomes of a baby in a woman and
for nine months they both had to bear
that child how quickly and then and then
at you know the nine month mark then
they merge and it becomes one baby but
equal weight or you just make men carry
around a weight over time throughout the
nine months men are so weak they
wouldn't even consider a nine-month
commitment to creating another human
being like literally literally a a man
gets off within you know 30 40 seconds
and that's his contribution to making a
nine month that the nine month process
it's like actually making another human
being boom 30 seconds that's a man's
contribution they pound their chest they
feel like they you know they won 30
seconds is equal to nine months for sure
yeah yeah yeah absolutely well and man
and man money and man money it is right
yeah
what a trio to discuss this stuff
so but yeah i would love to see a world
where that would happen if a man had to
be have for nine months the other half
right and if you really wanted it then
you had to fully commit
unfortunately we don't live in that
reality but who knows maybe somebody
evolution will change it speak speaking
of you brought up junior and if things
age well we all know that howard stern
has done some things in his past that
don't age very well um but i do want to
play this part where he makes this point
and i'm not sure exactly where it is so
bear with me here about the mask he's
talking about he's talking about this
see if i can get it to play here of
course it's going to look look at this
thing what the hell
tell me what kind of internet you got
over there
hey i'm trying to stream you gotta die
yeah
yeah just log on to aol we'll see look
looks like one looks like we're not
going to be able to watch this video
maybe it looks a little slow
yeah i don't know what's going on with
it it was working earlier everything was
fine let me oh here it is here it goes
here it goes here it is
the electoral college says and i guess
this was set up back in the good old
days
uh because they wanted everyone to have
some kind of representation but here's
what happened three million voters
were the majority who voted for hillary
clinton but they ended up with trump we
got a
minority president
who held views that were the minority of
this country
so much so that he lost by three million
votes that he became president
and then he did the country of favor and
found the most radical supreme court
justices who all agreed
that abortion was wrong they've been on
some sort of a secret list that not so
secret list
so we ended up with this scenario
and we also ended up with it when uh
again
you know uh obama didn't get to pick a
supreme court justice so okay so now we
have a minority viewpoint in this
country running the country if it was
the majority viewpoint all right you put
up with it but it's the minority
viewpoint now how much more are we going
to take
how much more of this [ __ ]
that some hillbilly in south dakota gets
a more important vote because he lives
in south dakota
let me tell you something here's what i
say all unwanted children should be
allowed to live at the supreme court
building with those justices and they
should raise every one of those babies
that crackpot uh clarence thomas and
that wife and all of them they can raise
these babies so i obviously skipped over
the part that we were looking for but ed
you know that's that's a good one let me
see if i can find anti-abortion
and then we're stuck with them society
is stuck with them the people who are
anti-abortion they don't give to charity
they don't raise these kids i don't know
who they think is going to raise them
but um you know
you saw men if men got pregnant it would
be a different story no man would want
to be raped and then have to carry his
rapists uh baby
um men were ready to tear this country
down because we asked them to wear a
mask let alone have some baby they don't
want there it is like that that is the
that is the key like literally they
wanted they wanted to tear the entire
country apart to make sure that in in
their communities that they weren't
spreading a disease and getting people
sick and dying you really think these
[ __ ] men
would carry a baby
period but carry a baby who was
of their rapist and a baby that they
don't want get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] there's no way that that would
even be a reality or a possibility that
men would put up with and really frankly
women shouldn't put up with it either
they shouldn't they shouldn't put up
with this idea that they have to they
have to go along with this fascist [ __ ]
that they don't have to have the liberty
and the bodily autonomy to make the
choices that they want to make for their
healthcare and their doctors and their
bodies it's just ridiculous i want to
take a second so i actually compiled
some resources if i can share really
yeah go ahead absolutely for people
listening if you feel empowered by
what's happening and you want to help
and support organizations doing the work
and our grassroots or national or local
depending i have some people for you to
follow and help out so obviously planned
parenthood largest sexual and
reproductive health care center and
provider in the country
abortion funds which is a national
network of local abortion funds and it's
like between the aclu
and
yeah split will be split between
different abortion funds also aclu which
is illegal and
advocacy org leading the fight on the
legislative end um plan c pills so if
you probably heard a lot about this my
friends started this organization
they're incredible and they provide
abortion pills by mail also an
incredible resource for people the
yellow fund funds abortions and promotes
reproductive justice in the deep south
and that's the video that you saw
earlier if you were tuning in that nine
to five parody was um in support of that
amazing organization
the mariposa fund which is an abortion
fund for undocumented people and the
lilith fund which covers the cost of
abortions for texans who couldn't
otherwise afford it so let's remember
with this case
it's people in marginalized communities
people that can't afford to put gas in
their tank and drive across state lines
to get an abortion that's who you really
need to be concerned about and just in
general
all people that are affected but more so
if they can't physically be able to go
to a different place they're [ __ ]
so consider giving and i'll i'll send
these to tony and gabe so you can check
them out yeah yeah yeah we'll throw them
in the chat and we'll uh we'll send out
if you if you tweet it we'll retweet it
you know or if you just send it to us
then we'll then we'll tweet it here's
the other thing that i'll do is we'll
cut the part where you're talking about
it and i'll get our uh editing
department gabe can you get our editing
department to put this let me on the
video sorry yeah are you guys hearing
this
you got it yeah yeah right
okay okay cool yeah we're good yeah yeah
look at the graphics with the with the
links and stuff uh maybe uh logos or
websites or something uh we'll try to
put a video together so we can uh post
it on our twitter page and we can share
it around twitter so that so that
everyone can see it uh missy thank you
for joining us thank you for having me
do you have a heart out because i have
one more video i want to show you there
was one let's do one more video okay so
so this one here is the good liars i
love the good liars adore those guys
walter good liars they do so much good
work don't they
they're so they make me laugh so much
this this video here is only 30 seconds
but it encapsulate the absolute [ __ ]
hypocrisy when you see these
quote-unquote pro-life women right
they're anti-women women and sometimes
and i i've had discussions with my wife
about this sometimes the most anti-women
people
are women and for whatever reason the us
men have created this culture it's kind
of what she talks about like men have
created this culture where women have to
be anti-woman because there's only so
many seats
at the round table for women and they're
very few and far between and the only
way to make your way to that seat is to
elbow other women out of the way and and
to be more of a macho machismo type
woman i guess and that's kind of what
she says i believe it's true but let's
let's watch this video here
this is apparently a rally where these
women are holding up a sign that say uh
adoption they're pro-adoption you know
they want to uh send these babies for
adoption but let's let's watch
this video
i i saw the sign choose adoption
and how many how many children have you
adopted not able to adopt
i'd love to adopt she's not able to
how many children have you adopted
so you've adopted i have two of my own
so clearly clearly the lady at the end
she finally caught on to what was
happening because she's like two of my
own like she didn't say i've never yeah
because the other three like nope i am
adopted i was unable like what do you
mean unable yeah
you mean you can't afford it because
wait wait are you saying that yeah i was
like also are you saying that it's okay
because it was expensive that you
weren't able to adopt just like for a
woman who you're forcing to have a
pregnancy it might be an expensive thing
to go with and she might not be in the
situation where she's able to do that
you're you're saying that that's okay
for you not to adopt for those reasons
but it's not okay for a woman who who
has been forced to have a pregnancy
interesting
they're i also just love their delivery
because i think it's important and what
you both do so well we're all angry but
i think we come across just like pissed
it's not gonna
it's not gonna hit people in the way you
want them to you want people to feel
upset and angered but also like
empowered to take action otherwise we're
all just gonna be sitting
and just feeling paralyzed by the
situation
absolutely absolutely um they all want
your shania twain parody
yup it's so wild thank you for the super
chat caitlyn
yeah
oh no it's just funny it's not funny
it's
how
i create well this video is more recent
i think i did that last month but i did
a video
five six years ago and the message is
exactly the same nothing has changed in
fact it's probably gotten worse
well so that so that you want shania
twain have you seen that one tony uh i
believe i have um i i you know what i'll
do is i'll do the same thing i did with
your nine to five i'll go post it on
twitter so everyone um
go go to the our twitter page the
personal shrine to me today on tony's
twitter right at tony michael spot i've
been i've been um
you know plugging missy all day long and
we'll continue to plug missy i haven't
checked i actually had a doctor
appointment like early this morning
hence why i'm a little
tired
oh good
do you want me to you want the link for
the video i could play it right now do
you have it yeah go ahead yeah
yeah
it was watching you play this
yeah i was what the whole the whole show
i just kept watching the uh that's why
he didn't answer some questions it was
in his ear yeah i was just like
listening just i was in i was in my own
world yeah well yeah send me send me the
uh send me the link here and you got it
there i'm trying to do uh i'm trying to
do two things at once well yeah yeah
yeah i'm trying to get bonehead of the
week
you know about bone end of the week we
do bone in the week every week it's a
pool
and um yeah i do of course yeah yeah the
bone of the woman
like bone bone and steak i'm like oh
uh yeah bonehead though he is a
contestant this week on bonehead of the
week yeah he was like
i think so yeah this is yeah it was the
first concert i ever went to fun fact
look at that yeah love her so much
okay so here is here this is this is her
instagram so people go follow her yeah
go follow missy on instagram let's
unmute it
that's all
okay so what is this explain this to
this video students before we uh play it
this is
what it's like to feel like a woman
right now so in 2022 and beyond like
what truly it feels like and obviously
it's satirical because my whole thing is
sometimes it's so dark that i have to
laugh or else i will cry so this is just
me taking information that's very
disturbing and singing it with a smile
so you might recognize some headlines
and fun facts
so let's let's play the video here this
is a parody of shania which song of
shania twain's disappearing i feel like
a woman i feel like a woman okay let's
watch
let's go girls
this includes everyone that has the
uterus
[Music]
i'm going out tonight i'm feeling so
alright i wanna let it all hang out
so let's make some noise for our lack of
choice yeah i'm feeling so alive
[Applause]
[Music]
the best thing about
[Music]
force me praise be
[Music]
nobody cares
[Music]
i think the best video we watched all
day
frankly i i'm a big fan of uh of all the
little
headlines and snippets here i also
really enjoy the fan uh effect
it's so funny how critical i am i'm like
oh god i'm like so handsy i'm like
touching my hair the whole time yeah but
it plays so well yeah yeah i i haven't
seen the original music video in quite
some time so i would imagine she's also
probably yeah shaking her hair
that was 90s song right yeah yeah
absolutely you know yeah yeah yeah and
then shania twain so she would you know
she would be doing the hair thing in the
fan and all that it's like if you didn't
if you just i feel like if you're just
saying with your hands down it wouldn't
sell you know like it yeah it would it
would feel a little weird if you're just
like i feel like like you know the hands
got to do something you know you gotta
you gotta sell it
you know missy i really appreciate you
being here i really do and we gotta we
gotta bring you back more often yeah
anytime you wanna anytime you wanna drop
in yeah anytime you wanna talk about
anything or what or if you want to air a
video now i will tell folks that i i i
suspect that youtube is going to knock
us on her parodies probably so what we
will try to do is if youtube knocks us
i'll try to put we'll put the the links
um to missy's tic toc or instagram and
to some of these videos on twitter so
all that stuff is there so if if if you
go to this episode on youtube and you're
not finding the video or it gets cut
because of youtube
go down in the description look down the
description the link will be there and
and go follow missy on twitter i've
tried since i've met missy to get her on
twitter to get her on the tweety and she
doesn't she doesn't
she
shows up sometimes and then leaves
seldom
do you know why i'm triggered because i
was so trolled on twitter that was
really is that what it was i think we
talked about it last time you were here
that was the place of like
i have ptsd so maybe i need some like
training from the masters here
you know yeah you just ignore you just
yeah you just don't go to your
notifications it's easy to say just
ignore but it is one of those things
where you're like i'm just gonna i'm
gonna laugh back at you because you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] wherever
i've started to troll the trolls we
actually turned one the other day yeah
we did yeah yeah we turned one into a
viewer i hope they're watching i hope
they're watching yeah
yeah also yeah but but uh yeah we've had
bissi on before and uh if you guys want
to check out that interview where she
talks about the whole creative process
and everything that she does in terms of
her her singing and her background uh
please go check it out it's uh it's on
you can find it on the youtube channel
and it was a wonderful wonderful
interview you two are amazing thank you
thank you thank you i'd love to be back
yeah
grateful for you both and thank you and
one last thing before you go because
we're going to go to a break here missy
and it is a break that is special
because it has both of you and gabe in
this video it is
it is uh what's it called the droop is
that what it's called the droop
is this the premiere of the droop no no
no no we played it we played play it in
a commercial break people love the droop
they love the jerusalem so we're gonna
play
have a great weekend missy and thanks
for coming back we'll see you soon
everyone stick around be right back and
watch this commercial stay around for
this commercial you're going to want to
see it for the group with uh starring
missy motel
and gabe sanchez
we'll be right back thank you missy
we'll see you soon bye bye
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew feed the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
you we have reached the second hour
of the tony michaels podcast here on
friday you know what that means
we go to bonehead of the week let's see
if i can get the transition right here
uh gabe what do you think did i get that
transition right now
it was close
it looks great yeah it does it does look
at this look at this new art are you
guys enjoying this is the audience
enjoying the new bone end of the week
art look at that bow
boom
boom
i like having missy on she's fantastic
she's great she is fantastic
the parodies are
unstoppable really if you go to her tick
tock account like you could spend like
12 days there probably and her instagram
too for that matter um and we we have to
everyone out there give missy some love
on twitter we got to give her some love
on twitter so she knows that twitter
isn't just a swamp that there are really
good people out there so anyone out
there
on twitter that loves to see missy on
the show loves missy's videos go give
her some love on twitter so she will
post more on twitter post or videos more
on twitter we would love to see that but
go follow her on instagram and the tiki
talks and
it's missy modelling it's m-o-d-e-l-l
missy model you want to put her handle
down there in the uh the chat here i'll
put it in there i'll put it in there
while i look at the links
we're gonna we're gonna go to bone head
of the week bonus of the week was uh
ah there was so much bone-headed [ __ ]
this week that um we had a little bit of
trouble and the reason why is because
almost all the bone-ended [ __ ]
uh was directed towards the topic that
we were talking to missy about gabe was
this
this draft leak
of the fascism that the bought and paid
for federal society supreme court not
our united states supreme court the
federal society supreme court to
overturn the liberty of women in this
country
um almost all of the bone ends this week
was directed in
at that topic a few of them were not we
know madison cawthorne is getting um
attacked by
republicans for having a butt mohawk i
mean excuse me being involved in sex
orgies or just being an [ __ ] and they
want to get rid of him i i think i think
that's that's the case here because he
ended up on the bonehead of the week
poll too um
yeah he got more votes than i thought he
would gabe i i you know i know well i
went to bed last night thinking like all
right
well i mean like you know the the clear
the clear winner
uh
uh that um
won this week you know was wha was
was in the lead last night however
there were there were a couple changes
that here that happened here and there
uh in the last few moments on really on
youtube and on twitter didn't really
change the total outcome
but it did fluctuate the the where i had
to place them on the chart okay well
let's let's do this let's start the
bonehead of the week here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week
where you vote you decide and we break
it down
every single friday in the second hour
of the tony michaels podcast you can go
vote on twitter at tonymichaelspod
just go follow us over there you can
also if you're on the tubes of you you
can subscribe to our youtube channel and
then you can vote on youtube as well now
it's starting this this was the first
week we we did it we did it it worked
people told us your questions i saw it i
saw it in the comments they said hey not
everyone's on twitter man it happens i
said all right i hear you i feel you
i'll let you vote
here's our here's our contestants this
week we know uh uh butt mullet or butt
mohawk or representative madison gothorn
well it's like a but like a hedgehog you
know yeah well uh ask watch that's i
guess watch an askwatch that's i come up
with that name i think the other day i
said ass sasquatch but i thought ah just
complying
together and an askwatch oh askwatch
there maybe that'll be my nickname for
madison gothorn from now on you know
some people some people gabe call him
sittler i think that's highly offensive
so i will not call him hitler nope um
i'm gonna call him askwatch
squatch that'll be that'll be good
oh my god ask watch uh we also had uh
susan collins and you've seen their uh
the united states federal society
supreme court justice alito
for the decision i actually voted if you
look here um on my page let's see here
if i can bring this up i voted for susan
collins on the uh
wow
that's what i did and the reason why i
vote i voted for susan collins was
because i figured you know these ass
wipes she lied they lied to her um one
of the issues is why we have three trump
supreme court justices because of susan
collins lies and her her dumb [ __ ]
right i i was like gorsuch pointage
promised me he wouldn't right cavanaugh
promised me he would have me right
whether whether she actually believed it
or not i don't know i think she's an
idiot and i think the state of maine
deserves much better than her as a
senator we'll also agree to only two
terms
of service the other reason why she's on
the bone of the weak bull poll gabe is
because she said she will not support
right she said
it was too broad yeah it's too extreme
to give women their rights right oh my
god
so between these three on uh you see you
see here the results on twitter um for
the twitter poll here um
you know
oh
susan susan collins susan collins let's
see if we can watch some video maybe of
this bonehead let me see if i can find
some something i'm sure you can find all
the receipts where she says
they can't be overturned it's precedent
they promised me he might have touched
it a video i think it was lying gqp yeah
i think and then what it was called
yeah let
see if we can find that um
video
while you're doing that i hope everyone
out there is having a good friday uh i
hope you're all gonna do something fun
this weekend or you know just you know
relax a little chill netflix whatever
netflix and chill i mean you don't have
to do both you could just
chill and do netflix you have the
netflix and chill you know oh but i'm
just saying you know like you could go
out and you know you want to go for a
hike or go hang out at the park or
whatever go to the bar non-bone-headed
type stuff or just again hang out at
your house and just watch netflix that
sounds great
so let's watch this video that minus
dutch did of line gqp and it features um
one of the contestants
which is
susan collins's watch i believe the
constitution protects the right to
privacy
and i have no reason or agenda to
prejudge the issue
[Music]
roe versus wade is an important
president of the supreme court it was
decided in 1973 it has been challenged
on a number of occasions and the supreme
court has reaffirmed the decision when a
decision is challenged and it is
reaffirmed that strengthens its value
roe versus wade decided in 1973
suppressed the united states supreme
court
it has been reaffirmed so a good judge
will consider it as precedent of the
united states supreme court worthy as
treatment of president like any other
[Music]
as a judge it is an important precedent
of the supreme court by it i mean roe v
wade and planned parenthood versus casey
been reaffirmed many times
casey is precedent on precedent
[Music]
i do not believe that brett kavanaugh
will overturn presidents are overturned
all the time
bear dover turned off the title he views
precedent not just as a legal doctrine
but is rooted in our constitution neil
gorsuch for whom you voted don't you
think he's probably going to vote to
overturn roe versus wade if given the
chance i actually don't
row is not a super precedent because
calls for its overruling have never
ceased but that doesn't mean that rose
should be overruled
now obviously all these [ __ ] could be
on bonehead of the week this week
um and but but this video
and the fact that susan collins
were to
it seems like a lie to the american
people but to her constituents in maine
is probably the main reason why
i decided to vote for susan collins now
you know i don't know if that was the
correct decision but we'll we'll we'll
work through it um now
our one of our other contestants here
madison catherine we know
oh my god do we
do we do we know more about madison
gotham than we want to know um this week
was definitely revealing
uh
you know of
some
private stuff right and you know
the whole sketch no ask watch video yeah
no one here's the thing nobody asked for
that video uh but uh but it found its
way on the internet and um
you know
we said it yesterday you know
unfortunately we had to comment on it
because it is
unfortunately part of the political
sphere right now whatever that means
whatever that means yeah i don't know
you know what is politics in the year
2022 because it's an absolute [ __ ] show
if you watch this video um
it's hard to
play it on like youtube uncensored so
gabe made a censored version where it
has madison gawthorne's head um and and
the best part about it gabe and i know i
don't i can't figure out if that video
is hilarious like the original one if
it's hilarious if it's gross like it's
it's all kinds of mixed feelings i mean
but the one you made the one you made at
the end where the head is like
the head is moving with the humping
that's the best it's hilarious it's
hilarious and speaking of that i got uh
and madison got there and paulie teaks
did a a video here and that's why i'll
preview that but he says um he says
breaking madison cawthorne oh i haven't
seen this one proposes a gqp
congresswoman susan uh dilemmas on the
steps of the people's house in new
hampshire so this is a state rep and her
name is susan dilemma she's a state i
noticed she's a state senator or state
rep she and they state she's a state uh
uh representative right right right in
that state she's an elected official
this is what she's do deciding to use
her right she goes on the steps as she's
entering which hey she's got the freedom
to yell and scream back
but let's let's act like a professional
here well do you really think anyone in
the republican party i mean jesus
here i'm asking for a miracle i know i
understand that i get it askwatch
himself admitted that they have the
cocaine field orgies yeah i mean
you saw what happened to him he's right
exactly on the gop and they're like well
apparently in this fix that paulie teak
says here um because she's yelling at uh
uh pro-women
supporters at the capitol who are
pro-women who are who are there to fight
for women's rights and she's yelling and
screaming at them but let's see how if
if paul
fixed the video here um and i don't know
what this has to do with madison
cawthorn but we'll find out
[Applause]
i can't even hardly look away um
if everyone's watching it appears that
madison cawthorne is um
maybe i don't know
um
seems to be forcing himself on the back
of that woman's head i guess so i guess
so thank you for the fix ball we really
appreciate it here on uh on bone end of
the week um
really honestly that video
by paul right there it almost
encapsulated our whole week of politics
and that one crazy video there don't you
think yeah i mean
jeez you know the day when you could
think back to like oh bush was dodging a
shoe
to
now these guys are
are getting videos released of them
humping and
assaulting and
now it's a dog with madison hawthorne's
face on and humping the back head of
this woman who's insanely screaming at
pro-women
like what uh
it just gets the whole week in one
little video one little video so thank
you paul i i'm i'm i'm a fan of paul i'm
a vanna ball uh here's another video um
apparently you last week uh marjory hoof
foot green
was on excuse me marjorie trailer i see
marley marjorie no no we got
confirmation yesterday she has at least
four toes right but she's still a hoof
foot yeah yeah yeah yeah i can still
guard her but i can't call her three
toes right right right right right i
think she's nicknamed three toes right
the three toes that nickname
it's been debunked it has been debunked
we'll show you proof here in just a
second of that if we can do that on can
we do that on bone of the week bring in
someone who's not exactly just because
we bring it up the proof we can do that
i mean you mentioned her name okay well
we're allowed so here is a video
apparently um this is another reason why
madison gother and i don't know if he's
trending or not but you remember last
week we had uh
acosta from cnn he he was following
marjorie taylor green hoof foot and he
was asking her
about some things about tapes and text
messages and perjuring herself
on the stand at her hearing and she did
not like that and i believe that's why
she ended up on bone end of the week
last week or one of the reasons why
right right but he did the same thing
to madison cothran apparently he had to
run a little faster i think though
because uh um
madison
can roll away as opposed to run away so
let's let's watch
let's watch what happens here in this
here's what happened
congressman you got a second just want
to ask you about the meeting with you
mccarthy
he said what you said we gotta get the
vote
any chance we get a quick comment here
at the crosswalk
what's that just trying to take our uh
quite secondary football actually
unrelated question about
president trump saying that uh he wanted
to get dirt from putin
you know what now that i'm seeing this
gabe
this this video is from uh from a while
ago but people are circulating this
around i wonder if if today if if if jim
could ask him a question if he would ask
him what the hell is that in your ass
yes yeah yeah one confirmed did you see
between the cheeks what what in the [ __ ]
is that what in the hell is that we've
seen a lot of things of what people
believe it to be some people say it's
hair some people say it's a toy some
people say it's
something else
right
we have no idea we literally have no
idea and the only question i can answer
that question is either his cousin
allegedly
or
madison catherine himself right and
speaking of man scotland we played this
video the other day which i think is a
really important video um this is way
more important than any video that
you're gonna see of him doing whatever
the [ __ ] he's doing with his cousin um
because this is the video that matters
we talked about this the other day this
is from april 4th
uh 2022 so this is not just over a month
ago
and this this speech goes into official
record as his belief and his opinion on
the house floor so this video here has
way more uh should have way more weight
and why we shouldn't [ __ ] vote these
kind of fascists in so watch what he
says in this clip just over a month ago
for
and and to reassure all the people out
there his his butt mohawk is not in this
video it is just him speaking speaker
the left has ripped away the pin of
truth from the author of life
they've exchanged natural science for a
party platform and declared war on
biology
your left wing movement is forcing
children to endure radical expressions
of sexuality and yet you can't even
define what a woman is
you might have been to bill but you'll
never amend biology
science is not burger king you can't
just have it your way
i am the youngest member of the house of
representatives and i never imagined
that one of my sacred duties in this
hallowed chamber would be explaining to
the house speaker the difference between
a man and a woman
take notes madam speaker i'm about to
define what a woman is for you xx
chromosomes
it's so simple
the condescending [ __ ]
fundamental scientific fact
that woke liberals in silicon valley to
strip you of your voice and ban you
until you bow at their altar of
falsehoods
patriots like charlie kirk and tucker
carlson have been muzzled on twitter for
promoting the dangerous and bigoted
ideology called science
madam speaker you no no it's it is
[ __ ] bigotry it's anti-science it's
all [ __ ] patriots patriots yeah
patriots [ __ ] patriots right
you [ __ ] also this is what i mean
look look i'm not saying that
homeschooled
uh
you know comes out with these results
but this kid is giving homeschooling a
very bad name
uh
and uh yeah we should definitely fund
public education just want to say that
again you know these people marger
taylor green greg abbott ron desantis
madison cawthorne all of these [ __ ]
idiots give a very good reason for why
we should continue to fund and and
fund more
in public education
um because you know they're trying to
ban things and obviously if you don't
educate yourself then you become one of
these indoctrinating
uh
you know brainwashed fascists that's
what the end result is right well it
never happened if you can't read about
it right here's the other thing too gabe
because i posed the question earlier
this week are are we
the people gonna let
more madison catharines be elected
because you said fund education we have
to fund some of these campaigns folks uh
shannon points out this um this video
here because you know a lot of this
culture that he's doing in that video
that the the ask watch video that we
watch you know we we surmise that this
culture is rampant all over and that's
what's happening in that video
but it's the it's the pro
i'm gonna shoot you to take our
government back you know it's not even
second amendment anymore it's we're
gonna kill you to to force our ideas on
you we're not only going to do that
we're going to make sure to kill women
if so they don't get medical procedures
we'll put them in prison if we have to
we'll jail them uh you know we'll take
away your rights now shannon points out
here this is a video
of a [ __ ] one of these [ __ ] fascist
uh and i believe it's in yeah it's ohio
and he's a congressional candidate uh
looks like j.r mad majeski i think his
name is majewski majeski majewski if
elected ohio congressional candidate
vows to rip down our closed signs and
shoot you with a semi-automatic rifle
unless you agree to return america to
its quote-unquote its former glory now
um
i want to ex i want to explain something
about what she's saying because this
isn't like this isn't like he got caught
on camera saying this [ __ ] right just
like that pastor right say hi production
right they are pretty put out juicing
this video
as
a video for his campaign
now again at the very top it says make a
great america dominant again this is
this culture and this is exactly what me
and gabe are talking about when we're
saying
that madison caught thorn is it just
because you've seen the askwatch video
and the where he's touching his cousin's
touching his crotch video in the car
that does not indicate sexuality it is
about male fascist dominance that is
what it's about it is this male [ __ ]
white male privileged i'm being
oppressed culture and i'm gonna shoot
and kill someone or i'm gonna hump
someone or tea bag someone if they try
to stop me here is here's this watch
this video it's [ __ ] gross but let's
watch it
their agenda is bringing america to its
knees and i'm willing to do whatever is
fascism to return this country back to
its former glory
so so at first he says to its knees and
he's alluding to it that's a that's a
homophobic uh trope there yeah um you
know he's he's saying he's saying that
liberals
um
uh soak corks as uh jimmy fallon would
say on a saturn a famous saturday night
live skit but he's alluding that's what
he's alluding to it's a it's a if if i'm
a white man and i'm watching this the
filter is that oh yeah it's it's a it's
a bunch of gays
right um giving fellatio that's what
he's suggesting and then which also but
i could also interpret that as like oh
you want to bring someone to your knees
it's like oh you now have to bow down
before me yes there is the sexual kind
of innuendo connotation that's there but
i look at this and i say
when you make that argument of like bow
down to your knees i can make that very
same thing and say when fascists take
over and tell you what to do and you
don't do what they say
and you don't bow down like you got to
get underneath and then i'm not saying
you'll be eliminated or executed but
they will remove you from the situation
because well he does he does he does
flip the he does flip the uh the gun you
know
he he does [ __ ] the gun right right at
the end there so let's watch the rest of
this
big gun right well you know it is a lot
a little dick you know in the closet
energy here
and if i got to kick down doors speaking
of that
that's perfect
there's not even a goddamn what's funny
is let's say that he is coming out of
the closet watch it here watch gabe
and if i gotta kick down doors
well that's just what patriots do
when i'm elected i won't bow what does
that mean what that's what patriots do
what is that what does that mean that
they're all coming out of the closet i
don't know maybe break down doors it
sounds like breaking and entering so you
guys are breaking the law well they they
did break into the capital they did kick
down doors to break into the game right
right well they [ __ ] you know what's
funny about that they had actually [ __ ]
in their hands yeah yeah just like they
they were like
smearing my own shoes
i wonder if they had like disinfectant
wipes or something maybe that hand
sanitizer i think you know they all
brought their little sandwiches and
their snacks and they were eating it
right with it you think they were eating
poop sandwiches eating sandwich yeah you
know
it happens [ __ ] eaters okay let's let's
let's listen to this [ __ ] eater little
establishment pawns or power hungry
radicals
i will hold my own and what's funny
about that power hungary radicals like
it's literally radical like literally
the extremist gqp is trying to do
everything they can to get
knuckleheads like this to come out and
vote for him like the most extreme
[ __ ] policies they want to jail women
for having a medical procedure charging
with a felony homicide felony homicide
for having a taking plan b if they need
it
oh my god this is [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ]
let's listen my own and demand that once
again america stands down independent
and strong like the country that i
fought for
patriots the cowardice ends with us it's
time to restore american dominance
what's funny go back sorry go back to
where he knocks the sign off yeah
correct
all right all right
yeah
play
patriots cowardice is with us
so obviously this is this is like an
abandoned warehouse is this an abandoned
warehouse is it just like knocking down
the sign makes this an open business or
yeah he's like
knocked it down we just totally should
do a parody of this video i know we
should totally do somebody minus margie
says uh
gabe should do a video threatening them
with a soda spray
[Laughter]
oh thank you audience thank you
listeners for apparently joining in
finally joining in with my sodastream
with uh uh joining in on giving gabe
[ __ ] about his sodastream thank you
audience thank you listeners for
following my lead there uh this is
perfect um what what what a way to get
into friday here so yeah maybe we'll do
a parody of this at this bonun because i
probably could do this i could do this
guy's voice oh yeah i mean oh i
definitely could yeah
you got you got
you got the woods around you and stuff
or you got a place where you can go i
mean you don't know we'll just take his
video and i'll i'll dub over him oh okay
yeah yeah
i was also thinking that maybe you could
just film in your house like like weekly
kick open the door maybe trip down the
stairs a little bit you know no i think
we keep the same video okay keep the
same video over yeah we just dub over it
maybe all right use part of his voice
part of mine i'll try to imagine we'll
do something like that maybe and you
know what you know what we'll do
and instead of airing it on twitter and
that stuff maybe we'll we'll put this on
the youtube uh saturday
s satire and parody yeah the certainty
saturday uh playlist i'm combining words
there it's friday man it's been a long
week
i'm getting to the end here so now we'll
put it on that playlist maybe that's
what we'll do we'll make a plan for next
week to try to get this out there and
then uh and then once it goes on you're
doing this weekend uh yeah exactly i'm
dubbing over this video um so
this is not if you want more madison
cothorns in this country now this guy's
running for state office i i believe
maybe he's running for
a state or a united states congressional
seat i don't know it's in ohio she said
ohio congressional candidate so it could
be state office or uh federal office but
if you want more madison cothorns here
you go here's the guy i'm sorry he's a
oh my god hold on wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait this guy is a mega rapper
who painted his lawn for trump
won
he won
he also went to dc
for the very sixth insurrection oh this
is perfect so uh us clowning this guy is
absolutely up our alley let's let's make
this guy a a tony michael's podcast let
let's let's figure out some content to
make around this [ __ ] chucklehead he
won the primary
so he is so he is on the ballot
and i think that's what she won the gop
nomination to ohio's ninth congressional
seat yesterday yes uh and i think that's
what why shannon posted this yeah and i
retweeted because they're like this
guy's a [ __ ] nut job do you want to
see his lawn
yeah sure give me a link to his lawn
we'll do that and then and then we'll
move to the next we'll move to our
dishonorable mention after we look at
this guy's lawn
mark esper
for those folks out there who don't know
mark esper held all kinds of information
that the american people should have
known to make a choice in an election
and he chose to hold it for profit
yep i'm sick and tired of these [ __ ]
well it's not surprising that they would
do this
so but let's let's let's do this let's
look at this oh
hang on here let's look at this guy's
lawn here first
he painted
his lawn
so it's hard to see there it says trump
2020 dash dash dash
so in other words he wants him to be a
dictator yep
and and then it says make america great
make america great i don't know what's
going on over here this is maybe a
continuation of the lawn maybe something
oh because there's blue here so yeah i
think maybe it's a flag
yeah it's a big trump flag i think oh so
he's he's he's uh
he took it all the way to the corner
yeah
[Music]
that's really cool you can see that not
from a from a helicopter or an airplane
probably because it's so badly done i'm
sure he was like yeah i want google map
or like google earth to find me what a
dumb [ __ ] um so back to our dishonorable
mention gabe
explain to our audience what pisses you
off most about this because it pisses me
off but what do you mark esper is
another one of these profiteering
[ __ ] who held on to information
and waited to release it in a book and
make money on it right the the
publishers are just as bad in the
scenario i get that they have to make
money and obviously they're gonna you
know the the juicy gossip cells and
whatnot but when you're someone who
holds on to information maggie haberman
reveals in her book that trump was
eating documents and trying to flush him
down the toilet you know bill barr's
telling his regrets of being in the
presidency bolton is revealing secrets
uh you've got uh uh who else
um bill barr john bolton i mean the
[ __ ] list goes on and on
stephanie grisham who says oh uh i'm
having a moment of
of uh
of 2020 hindsight and i've seen i i'm
having this this moment where
i i saw what happened and i was in the
presidency and i was the press secretary
for a short period of time and instead
of saying something during the time
she waited to then
release a book after the fact mark esper
this is two years after the fact we're
finding out that trump
wanted to bomb the cartel and the drug
labs that were in mexico and then from i
mean mind you from a landlocked missile
position and then blame it
on someone else and be like
america didn't do it that's how we got
our title today exactly and these people
you know bob woodward is another one
right he's he knew back in february that
trump said it was deadlier than the
virus despite the fact that the things
that trump were saying in public was
it's not so bad it's not as bad as the
flu uh it'll go away in two weeks by
easter it'll be all cured right
these are the people that held on to
this [ __ ] information so that they
could write a book about it and profit
these people are just as bad as the
people that they report on
they do not get a free hall pass because
they're being a hero or a patriot for
now coming forward
they are just as disgusting and vile and
hypocritical
as the people that they write about
and these journalists should be using
their power and these people from the
administration should be using their
power to come forward and speak out
about what's being done
not hold on to it
for the next or for rather hold on to it
for the highest bidder
so you were talking about how he wanted
to bomb mexico and donald trump jr maybe
we'll if you can find that tweet for me
i'll i'll pull that [ __ ] boneheaded
tweet up um but uh john junior said yeah
we should bomb mexico what are you crazy
of course that's a good idea basically
is what he said um but here's an
interview with esper himself by nora
o'donnell because the other thing that
was said about mexico that esper was
taken aback is when stephen miller you
guys know the ghoul the the gerbils
ghoul that is the nazi stephen miller
and was a um a campaign aide and he was
in the white house as an advisor yeah
actually
yeah he's the architect he's the
architect
of the border right uh yeah caging
children
in separating families he wanted to send
a half a million troops apparently to
the border our military he wanted to
send to the border which is not exactly
how it works um but let's listen to the
interview here who suggested that we
send a quarter million quarter million
u.s troops wrong to the border steven
miller we're in a meeting waiting for
the president to come out we're standing
around the resolute desk
and uh he's behind me and this voice
just starts talking about uh caravans
are coming and and we need to get troops
to the border
and we need a quarter million troops and
i think he's joking and then i turn
around and i look at him and he's in
these deadpan eyes it's clearly he is
not joking
and so i i say something like well look
dhs can handle whatever caravans are
coming up
so mark esper you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
why in the [ __ ] didn't you get on the
horn and let the american people know
that that's what these dumb [ __ ] wanted
to do you stupid piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] this is the most
un-american thing i've ever heard of in
my
really it is [ __ ] gross that this guy
is he was the secretary of defense
for defending our [ __ ] border
and here he is in a [ __ ] official
meeting with the goddamn president his
advisors and one of his advisors
has the stupid [ __ ] idea to send a
quarter million troops to the border he
thinks he's joking he realizes that he's
not he knows these people are trying to
remain in [ __ ] power he probably
knows they're trying to commit a [ __ ]
coup
why in the actual [ __ ] didn't mark esper
do this goddamn interview in 2020. you
spineless piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you were
not a patriot you were unamerican and
frankly you deserve to be cast out into
the history books as
as un-american and you tried to topple
our democracy because you withheld
information for money in your own mother
[ __ ] pockets that piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
the people the people from this group is
is profit over people right that is
exactly what they did and in the whole
[ __ ] caravan thing i just want to
point out there is no [ __ ] caravan
that is coming from mexico into the us
the only caravan is [ __ ] ted cruz
driving across the border to cancun okay
a dodge [ __ ] caravan that's the only
caravan there is not a group of people
that we have to worry about right these
people are trying to seek refuge and as
good republican christians we should
allow them to come in and give them
shelter right because you're easily
going to hire them for the services that
in jobs that you don't want to do but
then you want to complain you want to
complain that these people who are
trying to live or work for the american
dream
are not worthy
the same people who are trying to force
birth on women
the
it is it is insulting and disgusting and
someone who is
who is mexican a mexican-american so i
bare i i share both sides of the border
here
and to hear
whether it's i want to bomb the cartel
in mexico and blame it on another
country as if the u.s didn't do it and
to have someone like this who was
architecting this this vile disgusting
plan of of separating parents from their
fam from their children in mexico and
putting them in cages and then not only
that but then allowing mark esper
to then say yeah you know what yeah
we'll we'll uh we'll have you want to
write a book
right the publishers again these people
are just as bad as the ones that they
were poured on or that they want to like
be the whistleblower about but the
publishers in the situation
they're just as bad as them [ __ ] yeah
they're probably all in the same group
as [ __ ] let's listen to the rest of
this [ __ ] they've done so in the
past and he said and he said he repeats
no we need a quarter million troops and
i just turned squarely around to him
face him and say i don't have a quarter
million troops to send on some
ridiculous mission to the border and i
told this story to
general milley and my chief of staff you
didn't tell the american people you
[ __ ]
i said let's be safe let's just check
and make
sure in the building and milly comes
back days later
and the door opens up and he's waving
a document in his in hands and he says
something like secretary you're not
going to believe this
and that's when he explains to me that
yes they were working that we had
developed a plan initial concept of how
this might happen and i was just
flabbergasted that not only was the idea
proposed but that people people in my
department were working on it
so why why this [ __ ] didn't actually
alert of the american people to this is
is beyond me but also he just revealed
that someone in his own department was
doing something behind his back right
right spent time and resources and money
to come up with a [ __ ] stack of
papers that had a plan and then say hey
hey it's a real plan it's real plan but
instead of firing them instead of
removing them instead of calling them
out and casting them out like a leper
right
he says ah we'll keep him here we'll
keep him right
speaking of cast out like a leper we
need to get rid of this [ __ ] cokehead
this is ridiculous this is [ __ ]
absolutely ridiculous i don't know why
we have to [ __ ] listen to this
chucklehead yap and yap and yamp day
after day after day this is [ __ ]
ridiculous that we have to listen to
this
absolute bonehead booger sugar junior
here and this is all distraction here
gabe he says i'm still trying to figure
out
the recent media outrage media outrage
we talk it's human outrage you dumb [ __ ]
about my father possibly wanting to
target mexican cartel manufacturing
facilities in mexico no you wanted to
commit war acts
against a [ __ ] ally you dumb
[ __ ] the translation here is i'm
still trying to figure out why people
are outraged at the fact that my dad
wanted to bomb mexico right bomb mexico
and kill mexicans what a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] he said is that supposed to be a
bad thing listen to me folks when i tell
you this they're going to get on stage
at the next couple the next chapel trump
rallies and they're going to say this
type of [ __ ] they're going to say
hey it's a good idea that we should we
should allow donald trump to be
president so he can bomb mexico they're
going to say it folks they're going to
say it [ __ ] your tweet
meanwhile
don jr while he's writing this
is also oh no [ __ ] that thanks for the
tweet
uh meanwhile
don jr in this situation
is uh also afraid he's like oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] if they uh if they bomb mexico then
where's my supply gonna come from here's
here's gabe's uh here's gabe dude i i
rewrote this thing
probably nine to ten times there was a
lot of different things i was going to
say why'd you land on this word
it was the easiest way
what is it what does it mean what does
it mean it's uh it means like idiot like
uh something it's like a it's like a
nicer way to say the son of a [ __ ]
um but uh yeah i was i
i wrote out multiple lines of text that
basically was like i hate this
[ __ ] uh that is donald trump and
his son donald trump jr and i went
through when i went through and i went
through and i just was like you know
what i'm just gonna say spanish well
that's good there you go that's p
perfect perfect thank you for the tweet
okay let's move on um to
our alpha kevin mccarthy
why did we put the alpha cup as kevin
mccarthy we're running out of time here
so
tapes tapes tapes tapes tapes tapes you
know i tweeted i tweeted okay and you
pointed it out i think yesterday or the
day before i tweeted uh we got the we
got the uh we got the memo our emails we
got the tapes where's the vids and then
we got the askwatch video so yeah we had
that so um
so thanks kevin mccarthy for making
another appearance here on bone of the
week as the alpha cuck this week
but i want to go to our winner our
winner is
j chief justice samuel alito
of course we know in his decision
tell us gabe tell us have you read parts
of his decision tell us what you think
tell us what you think about samuel lido
and why he won here and then we'll we'll
give him right his uh
his justification for
um
his decision right his draft decision
was
uh it said it's opening the door to roll
back things for
hundreds of years right um he's there
are several cases that would you know
people would make
that could say oh you know what well
because this right was taken away we
also want to take this right which could
be interracial marriage we could be
same-sex marriage you know there's a
brown versus education people are
talking about which is you know like
whether
whether or not people should be you know
uh
in terms of in terms of race and
education like there are there were many
things that this could potentially open
the door for if you were to take one
right away then it's a slippery slope to
go well they're also kind in this
category and they're tangentially
related so we could also
do that right you'll find all these
southern states below the you know the
bible belt that will be fighting for
these things to go back to how america
really was make america great you know
bring it back to the confederacy right
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] the cheeto dust
confederacy right exactly these are the
the the type of reasoning that they put
in besides the fact that he just
outright lied right
just like the video that we watched from
midas touch it was every single one of
these supreme court justices who said it
was precedent it was established as law
it was uh it was it was it was not going
to be overturned right they had said it
was challenged and yeah because because
we see plant we see roe v wade and then
you see in the 1990s i believe it's 1992
exactly that we see planned parenthood
versus casey which rolled it back but it
all but not only did it roll it back but
it it solidified that the woman had to
write to her own body and the choices
that she made the other reason why this
[ __ ] bonehead ended up here he
actually wrote this in his decision here
in the draft that is uh the initial
draft domestic supply of infants so it's
like literally human beings are
inventory is how he reversed him that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] so let's let's do
let's give let's give uh federal society
alito because he's not i don't think
he's a supreme court justice at this
point he's not a chief either now [ __ ]
him um so
let's let's give him his do here for
bonehead of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] justice alito [ __ ] him hard over
and over [ __ ] him
ah thank you for joining us for bonehead
of the week again go to at
tonymichaelspod
and follow us on twitter for next week's
bonehead of the week you'll find it
thursday and then every friday in the
second hour of the tony michaels podgett
we go through your vote on bone of the
week you can also subscribe to our
youtube channel and find the poll there
from now on on our youtube channel do
not forget to go there and again this
this bone in the week airs every single
friday in the second hour of our show
and our show the tony michaels podcast
airs every single weekday gabe yeah you
know that monday through friday yeah
last week we started it we were like you
know what we're gonna go seven days a
week yeah that's right
and that's the other good point that i
want to make about bonehead is on
sundays now we will cut the bone end of
the week out of the show we will air it
on the youtube channel so that's why
it's important to go there we will also
download it on all your favorite
directories apple spotify google
you can find it there boom to download
it so not only will you have this great
video version but you will now every
single week on sunday
have the
bonehead of the week audio version
take it go for a run get that cathartic
that's right
you know that's right
uh gabe what a great bonus we thank you
everyone for voting this week um we'll
see today quite a week
today was
today was quite a quite a month a year
decade jesus christ thank you for
joining us bone end of the week stick
around we'll be right back for a couple
announcements on the show thanks for
joining us bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah it was close it was close i i had a
lot of fun today on the show we had
missy modell and she came on
we we broke down some videos with her
we'll cut that out as well as bone of
the week you guys can watch um missy
come on the show we'll we'll put that on
the youtube channel um and so subscribe
to the youtube channel again don't
forget to look out for that parody and
satire what i call it earlier they
called it uh tire pattern
charity and pat tire playlist
[Laughter]
[Music]
go follow that over on the uh the tubes
of you don't forget to subscribe if
you're on facebook thanks for joining us
you guys know we simulcast do you mind
us touch facebook page so if you're on
facebook and you want to catch some of
these uh
parody and satire videos
don't forget to subscribe over on
youtube the link is right there with the
video to our youtube channel so you can
go subscribe to that don't forget to
also download every single episode this
week and remember on the weekends we do
the best of the tony michaels podcast
this week i think we are i think we're
going to have some good clips to put
into the best of uh the best of the tony
michaels podcast best of the week yeah
so watch for that to be on saturday and
then on sunday we'll clip out bone of
the week and put that up for you guys to
watch just the bone hint of the week
um ma'am what a what a week we had
gabriel really they're really trying to
take away people's liberty they're
trying to ban [ __ ] they're really all in
on this fascist stuff boy they're all in
on the fascist stuff like ask watch was
on his cousin's face all in
all in gabe just forced lynn
oh my god well thank you everybody you
have a great weekend and remember to
join us next week every single day next
week monday through friday noon eastern
11 central nine pacific right here on
youtube twitter twitch and simulcasting
from midas touch facebook page until
monday have a great weekend everybody
but until monday surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking